[Musique]
c'est bien de belmont maïs ma femme m'a
quitté pour son patron jours lors d'une
réception il avait gardé les micro
branché tout le monde l'a entendu se
faire démonter ya toujours pire et peine
c'est pire
t'as plus rien la visite est en couple
et croisons une expérience tu vas perdre
tout des amis aussi ne m'avait plu c'est
pas parce que tu es très sombre et que
tu dois montrer ni avec toi sois pas
égoïste on va se consoler ensemble fut
qu'ennui dans ma grande vague
dis moi que tu as pas envie d'évrecy
même nelson mandela il a divorcé le gars
y passent la moitié de sa vie dans les
prisons sud africain qui tient il pas si
vilain coup j'en peux plus j'arrive pas
et divorce
j'entends faire son mandat allait bien
j'étais pas bien bent et sabu 2 écoute
moi bien fait tomber de cheval ça arrive
aux meilleurs mais il faut que 3 m en
salle direct sinon tu te ra du poney
tout avis par de regarder
meilleurs amis pensent des vma thibault
quoi ça elle est devenue très
protectrice depuis mon divorce
bonjour ça
[Musique]
tabiou quoi mais huawei j'ai vu parce
que c'est mon ami
alors les copains m'ont fait une
surprise
papa
bien un truc qu'il faut pas toucher
la ferrari 250 gto
mais nous prenons le fameux
je suis au petit quoi je tiens même à
l'identique
ce cas bien hubert aux symboles porte
son nom